okay this next one is an unexpected
video two characters uh one I really
dislike and one I uh probably I'm gonna
dislike so let's listen to what they
have to say and uh a lot of the things
that you said that you've been called
out on specifically in regards to like
women driving as a matter of fact are
just generally untrue there's no
empirical evidence to back up those
claims which is why you resort to
anecdotes quite frequently and say
things like oh well it's just common
sense right
but it's not technically common sense
it's just your personal opinion
completely it's my personal opinion
based on my personal biases of my life
experience now when I say these yeah
exactly and when I say these things x
amount people agree with me and x amount
people disagree with me that's fine and
that's the same of nearly any statement
in the world I can say the world is
round and there'll be a percentage
people who disagree with me that's
totally fine I come on here and talk
about my own personal experiences and my
experiences men are better drivers and
women that's fine you can derive your
truth from internet study on a bunch of
different things the truth of life is
the truth that you experience as an
individual that is the only truth that
we all live within you live within your
truths I live within my truth because if
the truth I've experienced as an
individual that doesn't make your
opinion equally as valid that's the
Kinder saying uh well my opinion is that
uh this guy's orange and some people
agree with some people that's not the
way it works in fact don't these red
pill guys say some very peculiar but
whenever women bring up their anecdotes
not this is something like a facts don't
care about your feelings I wouldn't know
[ __ ] your feelings oh yeah yeah sounds
familiar right yeah well we don't care
what you've been through
there are facts in the world yeah ain't
that something they say they always
claim that women are illogical incapable
of looking at the stats the situation
and relying on their personal anecdotal
stories y'all could deliberate that as
much as you want at the end of the day
just because you showed me a paper that
says Oh supposedly statistically you
know this is no that's [ __ ] no but
but hold on hold on do you know what the
definition of a fact is a fact is
something that can be independently
verified through other means you cannot
agree to disagree when it when a fact is
stated it is a fact and what you have
your interpretation and appreciation of
it is different but you cannot disagree
with the fact the sky is blue you can't
sit there and be like I disagree it's
green yeah
it is blue oh now you're just here to
argue well that's your opinion or I
disagree
what you just sound stupid the world
operates the way it does [ __ ] your
feelings this isn't my experiences men
are better drivers and women no good
female drivers I'm almost like a female
cat no no you're misunderstanding what
I'm saying
there is a truth and then there is your
own personal experiences backed by
anecdotes right or your own personal
opinion backed by anecdotes from your
own personal experiences now your own
personal experiences are oftentimes
going to be incorrect
and and not close to the reality that's
why there's an entire field of
statistical analysis that's why we do
empirical uh that's why we rely on
empirical evidence when we're making
decisions why because we all carry a
bunch of personal biases and when we
analyze situations we do not have enough
scope to grasp the entirety of the
situation we didn't we cannot comprehend
it with our human brains bro listen
which is why when it comes to women
driving it's a funny point because the
truth is different the truth is the
exact opposite no no listen first things
first there's lies there's damn lies and
there's statistics I'm sure you've heard
that from Mark Twain that's the first
thing the second thing is that you're
you're derived yeah you can massage
numbers but you can drive you're
deriving your truth from an internet the
fact that you're going on the internet
finding some study and saying that this
is the truth especially after the age of
coven all the [ __ ] truth we were told
with that garbage you want to sit here
and say oh the internet said X I'm sure
the internet did I'm talking about my
personal experiences and some people
agree with me and some people do not
that is perfectly fine don't give a [ __ ]
if people agree with me or otherwise
people are listening to me and they're
either I know but you're still wrong and
that's the problem I disagree with you
do you want to be right or do you want
to keep speaking into a hug box where
people agree with you and then you know
well if you just completely devalue
empirical evidence Actuarial Sciences
the entirety of the insurance industry
that relies on making these sorts of
calculations to ensure that these quotes
are as profitable as possible which ends
up uh charging men higher rates than
women as a statistical likelihood that
men are more dangerous drivers than
women across the board and get into more
car accidents across the board if you're
going to look at all of that and say it
doesn't matter because that does not
correspond to my own personal uh my own
personal experiences then you're silly
you're being silly you're being a silly
person he's not wrong
I mean
the car insurance industry have every
vested interest in making sure these
statistics are accurate so they can
charge people accordingly and maximize
their profit do you want to see these
companies are cooking up these studies
to be inaccurate
so that they can shove themselves and
shoot themselves in the foot what are
you smoking
of course
so on this point Hassan's absolutely
correct and have no problem saying that
despite how I feel about it he's right
but if it does correspond with how I
feel I don't care about the study I
don't care about the facts
it's interesting how you remember what
we said before that a lot of these
feminists and a lot of these reptiles do
start sounding the same after some time
yeah the two extremes the two extremes
yeah the two extremes are very close to
two extremes are very close to each
other I mean [ __ ] are on the
same side and to his credit Hassan at
the beginning said you guys are two
sides it's the same coin and I don't
disagree with enough because remember
when Mario was out there screaming yeah
I'm better than you [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
isn't that the same kind of thing that
the sjws do when they see somebody and
they start screaming at Jordan Peterson
ah and whenever and then whenever YP
what whenever white man
whenever white man do that was like oh
yeah he's doing that toxic but you're
doing the same thing same thing whenever
a woman does some [ __ ] like that you
know generalizing you want to call and
put her in a box but you're doing the
same thing my perfume got discontinued
you know what that means yeah that
perfume that I spent so much time
searching for the right fragrance is
unavailable so what am I gonna do huh
I'm gonna go to the store spend 130 200
250 on a perfume to try a perfume
absolutely not it's not what I'm gonna
do you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
go on this link below and click on it
because it's gonna direct me to scent
bird I want to find another fragrance
and I asked them to send me some uh
fragrances today we have Mercedes-Benz
we have a book commodity book commodity
and Atlas you just twisted and you spray
it and you know the thing is
there's a lot of perfume in there I
could do this all day all night long
smells really good that's mine oh boy it
smells good you can either have a
subscription monthly and they send you
all this The Descent that you choose you
can stop whatever you want whenever you
want and guess what on your first month
you're gonna get 55 off your first month
of subscription by clicking on the link
below and using the promo code
ap55 ap55 for 55 off thanks Sam burden
thank you very much for sponsoring this
wonderful video in my personal
experiences all the car crashes I've
been involved in all the times my car
was hit and all the negative experience
we're at fault that is now you can sit
here and say the insurance claims say
that I never said the insurance claims
don't say that I'm saying that I am not
comfortable with women driving because
of my personal experience those are my
personal experiences you can drag up all
the empirical evidence in the world you
want to try and drag up
the truth no that's not the way it works
that's not the way it works that's akin
to some woman saying because three men
have attacked me all men are violent
that's nonsense
it's the same logic
it doesn't mean it is the truth
we have to be able to take ourselves out
of our own experience to look at things
holistically to understand that our
experience is not defined the experience
for everyone especially when we're
coming out here and saying men are like
this we weren't like this if you're just
using your own subjective experience to
make all those statements true then of
course at some point we're going to look
at you like you crazy because it's like
you have your own biases if you grow up
in the hood and you only around hood
rats you're like well every woman's a
hood rat no just to win you encounter if
you grow up in a posh area and every
woman is snobby that's not gonna mean
that every woman is snobby just your
experienced life
there's a difference between saying ah
women in my neighborhood are snapping
saying women in general snobby the same
can be said for black people or white
folks or that's how we come with these
sweeping statements based off of nothing
but our own personal biases
anything you want to say yeah you're
you're you're you're a girl that says oh
man are garbage that's you
that's him oh man our trap that's you
that's you
because in her experience I always you
won't always when a girl says that you
want to hold her accountable not as the
people that you choose
okay
okay that's you
you the same [ __ ] same thing
same but whatever
let's keep playing
over and over and over and over again
you come on here deciding you really
want to stick up for the chicks and
maybe you know one of them will drive
over to your house it's cool we've got
better things look look let's be real I
don't think I need to be a male feminist
to be able to attract the women okay
however I haven't said that having said
that that was a funny implication all
right bro hey
hoes hey you think I don't get you think
I guess no [ __ ] I guess hey man did you
not know I used to make pickup videos
have you seen that [ __ ] where he's
making all kind of anti-trans jokes and
all that [ __ ] he said College was a good
time for me I was picking up [ __ ] on
Miami
we will never be able to arrive at G
meaningful solution or a resolution to
this conversation if we're both
operating on personal anecdotes and
hypotheticals that is not how you can
conduct an appropriate debate good so
now you're saying the thing I just said
I have my own biases my personal
experiences and I say them some people
disagree and some people agree and I
don't care all right hey hey okay hey
hey it's important you want to know why
it's important hey do you want to know
why this is important point because
every single time these red pill dudes
pretend that they operate on the truth
being outside of the Matrix being the
logical and the consistent ones you come
to find out when pressed a little bit
they are oftentimes just as fragile and
just as ego driven as the women that
they cling to hate and want to take down
yeah the so-called Superior beings as
they like to put themselves as are
operating on the same mode of operation
as the inferior beings quote unquote
that they don't like so I just think
that's what's interesting to me how can
you coach someone
if you aren't willing if if you're
saying I'm going to trust my ears and my
eyes right
how do you coach someone out of
listening to their own inner their eyes
their own eyes and how they view the
world meaning let's say there's a virgin
dude who says all women are [ __ ] when
you're telling him to come outside of
their own personal biases no to get
outside their own experience to learn
something different to him
you're right and they're wrong
so it's not about everybody coming out
of your he's not just a superior human
being to a woman he's a superior human
being to the people that he teach and
I'm just going to teach you to be a
little bit closer to my level okay which
is interesting because you say everyone
has their own truth but it's like you
don't believe that you don't believe
that everyone's truths are equal because
you go on Twitch to try to change
people's minds and realize that their
truth is wrong that their Paradigm is
wrong right you call yourself quote
unquote Morpheus and you're going to be
so that means that you think that your
Paradigm in your biases are correct you
get what I'm saying so that's when you
realize how flimsy a lot of this [ __ ] is
for instance I'm not asking you to
ignore your own personal experiences I'm
simply asking you to look at the data so
let's change the subject because you've
just proven me okay Andrew do you
believe well I didn't I didn't he didn't
really prove anything but it's cool uh
do you believe the Earth is flat or do
you believe the Earth is is spherical
round
two years
oh he took his headphones off he gets
very stressed sometimes and you know
yeah yeah it's cool it's important you
know sometimes you can't take the heat
sometimes you can't take the heat so you
gotta get out of the kitchen a little
bit
um Andrew do you believe the Earth is
flat around spherical Globe do you
believe it's around right but when you
walk outside it feels like it's flat
it feels flat but you believe it's round
why do you believe the Earth is round
because I have personal experience that
would prove to me that the Earth is
around oh your personal experience what
happened did you go up to the [ __ ]
moon is that how you figured it out
actually I flew up into space
she got him he got him he did that's the
dead but but it lasts even longer up to
this point
[ __ ] it's done yes all right it's done
because he's going to resort to humor
the discredit which it's done just move
on okay
we have over 100 000 students making
more than they invest each month if they
didn't make more than they invest they
wouldn't sign up the most successful
online educational platforms are there
multiple layers to make some money
yourself if you want to join and have
more information.com you can find out
yourself if you're too cheap to pay 50
and you're broken nobody give a [ __ ]
what you think anyway you've ruined the
stream everyone wants you out of it so
either change tune and get with the
program and be fun or keep sitting here
and talking sarcastic and really slowly
and repeating yourself and talking about
how you only believe what you see on the
internet because no one really gives a
[ __ ] and it's boring so let's move on to
some fun let's get the tempo up there
you go that's it you got him no but but
that's it it's boring it's not fun good
now we know what it's about it's not
about the truth it's not about Morpheus
in The Matrix no I'm not doing that no
no let's get fun
which is cool I'm not mad at it
but at least we know what it is we know
what it is it's all entertainment it's
all smoke and mirrors and fun so do you
think man at the end of the day that's
how I watch stuff I don't take him
seriously I don't see him as his Pariah
or someone I want to emulate maybe you
do and that's cool but you heard it from
his own mouth we're here for fun
so anything else you want to say oh no I
was done a long time ago thanks and
burden you're gonna get 55 off your
first month of subscription by clicking
on the link below and using the promo
code ap55